I will be an enemy of you. There will be
nothing that can stop me. And I want you
guys to understand this is not a threat.
This is a promise. There will be nothing
that can stop me. I will release every
single text message. I am, like I said,
very angry. I'll show you the text
between him and I. Look at this text
message, guys.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters,
and donate towards this message
inshallah. A new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1,10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makayama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalam alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends,
if you guys have been following
following up my channel with the whole
Charlie Kirks, that's a certain nation
killing. You will see that I'm very very
closely following this up because Israel
is behind it and is it's going to come
out. This truth is going to come out in
Candace Owens. This woman is I fear for
her life like she is going to be
executed like she's going to be
assassinated some way or another. Um
she's got text messages and these text
messages say so much about where this
guy was. So we're going to watch some
videos of Candace Owens in she's someone
we have to salute and respect that she's
consistent. She she is one Christian
woman even though I believe she was
inconsistent with Charlie Kirk because
at the end she can he can be your friend
but you know he was pro genocidal and
the fact that you know I'm not saying
speak bad of him but anyways let's get
straight to the video and I'm going to
show you the text message he sent her
before he's kidding. Check this out,
guys.
>> Was a couple of weeks ago before Charlie
uh lost his life. Uh Charlie was in the
Hamptons. He had uh essentially what was
staged, an an intervention was staged by
Bill Aman because Charlie's thoughts,
Charlie's rational thoughts about Israel
were a no no. This is this is not the
route that you should be going on. And
Charlie was surrounded by his friends,
his quote unquote friends. Uh, Bill Aman
was very upset and threats were made. He
was asked to dispute this narrative. Uh,
Max Blumenthal went out to him today and
Bill Aman came back and said, "I I have
receipts. I can show you." And he did
not provide the receipts. It was at this
time that BB Netanyahu was called and
Charlie was invited to Israel. This was
an
>> he was invited to Israel. Who else was
invited Israel? Guys, remember Elon Musk
where he said if you kill their kids,
you are breeding the next generation to
do you remember he was you know he was
supporting Gaza. He said that he's going
to open his um that uh communication
thing whatever wireless uh stalling or
whatever it is for the Gazian people.
Remember all of that? Remember that
before he was called to Israel just like
Charlie was to go to this camp which K's
going to tell you in remember you don't
ask yet so you can see the same thing
happened with him. I hope you guys
enjoyed the video guys. But before that,
please download the Salah Pro app.
Brothers and sisters, we are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibla finder, no ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more.
Brothers and sisters, we are not an app
that shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now, inshallah,
and enjoy guys. Let's go back to the
video.
>> Under duress situation, I would say and
I know that Charlie was offered a ton of
money in this moment. Turning point, I
guess if it needed to go to a higher
level, would would have gone to an even
higher level than it already was at. And
I know for a fact that Charlie
denied that funding, that Charlie denied
and what BB didn't include there, he
declined to go to Israel for I would I
would describe this as like, you know,
re-education camp. You know, we've seen
it.
>> Exactly. It's a re-education camp. It's
act It is a re-education camp. It's
basically, you know, you're making a
mistake, going against us, but we can
fix that. Just come here. Let's just
indoctrinate you and brainwash you
again. You know, yeah,
>> you made an uh-oh, but we can help you.
Another person that was there, and I am
not surprised this person was there. If
you've been listening to my show, Seth
Dylan, I said, "Any comment on this one,
Seth?" He didn't answer last night. This
morning, I said, "Need a comment ASAP,
please." He didn't answer. Then I
followed that up and I said, "Trying
again here. You were present when Aman
lost his mind on Charlie and when BB
invited him to Israel and Charlie
refused." Text messages immediately
following this meeting are circulating.
I find Aman's statement as though the
meeting was somehow cordial to be
incredibly disturbing. Are you at all?
>> So this was an individual. He was there
and he is refusing to answer. Look,
Candace is showing me re receipts
messaging. You was there. You know what
happened? Speak. Nope. Nothing said.
>> Those of you who think that you are
going to replace Charlie Kirk. Okay.
Kings are born. You don't just get to
depose and tell us that we're going to
follow this individual. Okay. I'm one of
the Masons of Turning Point USA.
You put a shill in Charlie.
>> She's talking about if I'm not mistaken,
Ben Shapiro. Ben Shapiro is the one Ben
Shapiro someone else who's replacing
Charlie Kirk. Now, for some reason, he's
a shill. Now, with all due respect,
Charlie Kirk was a shill. Charlie Kirk
was bought out. Now, Charlie Kirk, it
seemed like he was waking up that
reality again, which is shows that at
least there is some kind of sincerity in
Charlie Kirk. But again, Charlott was
also a shield. But now, Ben Shapiro is
the one who's picking up that mic that
his bosses carried out the execution.
He's picking up that bloody mic with his
bloody hands already. Okay. So, as you
can see, brothers and sisters, um Ben
Shapiro's hands were bloody before he
picked up that mic because he and his
buddies uh were most likely behind this
assassination. Not him directly, of
course. Kirk's chair in Charlie Kirk's
uh company and you try to tell us to
follow that individual,
I will be an enemy of you. I don't there
will there will be nothing that can stop
me. Okay? And I want you guys to
understand this is not a threat. This is
a promise. There will be nothing that
can stop me. I will release every single
text message. So to the those of you who
are trying that, I'm seeing the
messages. I am telling you to back off
right now. Like right now, don't do it.
Okay? Don't you think about it. I know
exactly who you are. I know exactly who
you were that were exerting pressure.
Don't you pretend to be noble now and
say nice things about Charlie Kirk and
think you're going to slide into his
chair, okay? Over my dead body, which
I'm sure can be arranged. Those of you
who think
>> as you can see which can be arranged.
She's basically saying Israel. This is a
a a government who have carried out so
many assassinations all around around
the world. People know it's Israel. But
check this message from Charlie Kirk to
Candace Owens. And think about it.
>> You know, I told you guys that uh
Charlie was going through a spiritual
transformation at the end and all of the
usual suspects were really angry that I
hinted towards that. What do you mean?
You're not allowed to say that. They
were attacking me, trying to make me
fearful uh to speak out and speak about
the things that I know. I'm not feeling
very fearful right now. Um
I am like I said very angry and I found
uh you know Charlie's favorite portion
of the song. I'll show you the text
between him and I because this feels
very relevant right now. Um, this is
again,
>> look at this text message, guys. And
tell us if you was in Charlie's mind.
What does this text message mean?
>> Lyrics directly from the song Power, but
I just needed time alone with my own
thoughts. Got treasures in my mind, but
couldn't open up my own vault. My
childlike creativity, purity, and
honesty is honestly being crowd crowded
by these grown thoughts. Reality is
catching up with me. Taking my inner
child. I'm fighting for custody with
these responsibilities that they
entrusted me. And that's a moment where
he is really speaking about how hard it
is like when you're saying no, this is
what I believe and they say you're not
allowed to believe that you feel like
you are fighting for custody of
yourself.
>> Wow. Wow. Yes. You are you are fighting
for custody of your own self, your own
values. when he realized what they're
doing is wrong. He realized and then
imagine you realize that but you can't
say that because you are scared for your
life and you are fighting for custody of
your own self which is the what the
truth so your own self is what to speak
the truth like Allah says in Quran speak
the truth even if it's against yourself
or your kin and something stopping you
so you are now abducted and you are
fighting for your own custody bro look
at that message clearcut showing he was
totally changing his views and that is
why Israel and Benjamin is trying their
best to put imprint in our memories that
Charlie could have supported Israel. No,
he did not anymore.
>> And I want to be very clear that I
believe, in fact, I know that towards
the end, Charlie was fighting for
custody of himself. I want to say that.
I want to say that plainly. And there
are lies that are being told and they
need to be slapped down right now.
Brothers and sisters, we really really
need to see that the fact that even that
Satan Yahoo was asked that there
speculations that Israel carried out
this guys that is humongous which means
the whole world is waking up and it is
the beginning of the end of Zionism.
They planned and Allah planned and he's
the best of planners. There is more
going to come out, brothers and sisters.
But I want you guys to keep it a close
eye. And Candace Owens, may Allah guide
her to Islam. She seems sincere. And all
I'm going to say is brother and sisters,
look after yourselves and know that
subhan Allah, Allah is the best of
planist. These things are going to come
out. I'm telling you, one day we're
going to find out the real truth that
they assassinated him just like they did
and the involvement with all the evils
around the world. Till next time,
brothers and sisters.
Metal.